cannot going to welcome to this video
playing shyest a soul and lost the first
game and I remember that one that was a
I was a somewhat odd game so something
was all about it I don't know what it
was and it was them that was that maroc
see bind game they're lost okay
he plays some the lasker variation of
the petrov with the queenie to the
obviously very solid way of playing it
so here I wonder if I should play play
age 6 or not but take take I don't think
he has a good discovered check for I can
probably flick it in
and now B should be six is more of a
possibility as 95 is not possible yeah
it's a fairly symmetrical position of
course that seemed group e8 next
probably came Knight age 45 is such
maybe an idea I don't know most might be
G form okay in case of a g4 g5 maruca's
better on h8
okay I wonder if 95 would be helpful
here this night is not really great but
you can say the same thing about my
piece here is also not great maybe B 5 B
5 and then 95 yeah maybe I shouldn't
spend too much time on this itself it is
a fairly slow position anyway and you
probably have some leeway what to play
king B - I guess
answers frequently see normally you
trade on the e-file
just trying to play for c4
yeah it's for its equal it's just equal
I have to be make sure that I'm not
falling too far behind on the clock but
then the increment is helping of course
you know this game is a little bit like
watching paint dry I know but somehow
you have to do you have to play those
kinds of positions as well okay now he
agrees to the Train d5 I wouldn't mind
to play d5 at some stage but this is 95
ever put more pawns on light squares
which is generally desirable maybe he
will take with the Innova doesn't for
potential outside Paso
the code Bishop f6 I'm 1097
[Music]
yeah so I've managed to pick this fix
this on the forum night to be five or
six he six is probably better even so
it's giving me a pawn here
and another poem
I cannot lose on time which is very good
yeah once in a while you have to play
you have to play those extremely dry
positions and simply try to go for small
things they are very small things and
then sometimes people make mistakes
there was such a such an equal game I
think it was just really completely
equal I mean I wasn't entirely sure
about some things that I did like b5 but
I mean maybe you can do that it gains a
bit of space and you have control over
those squares which is a bit yeah it's
not bad and now we had the groups the
rooks traded yeah it's an extremely draw
position I didn't want to go to d5 and
the engine suggests this move but yeah
you know I I wasn't ready computing that
this is working you know of course it
doesn't go c4 but some some slow move
with anything else felt she can go back
to d2 but that is better than better
than Ruby on the bishop d8 I was
basically just staying here I was
surprised and she just played f3 year I
was thinking maybe even bishop
- who comes into consideration and then
push it back with f3 but ok it's it's
still nothing of course h5 I put pawn on
a light square yeah I have half couple
on light squares and this is what I want
to do with this Bishop g4 yeah I was
thinking maybe F takes but this gives me
94 and should be okay you know on a
light square and yeah Knight see it
looks a bit odd but I had this
regrouping in mind but I 198 Bishop f6
it's it's again that's just equal but it
became a little bit odd later here and
now hmm I don't know c5 it's a according
to the engine okay but he has to be a
little bit on the lookout as now d4 is a
bit it's a bit weak it's just what it is
yeah I don't know here it's gone he has
to do this 196 again I'm just winning
winning this I mean if he goes here g5
that is not extremely intuitive I would
have expected this I put everything on
this square yeah yeah I'm better now I
mean he probably should simply two
t-shirts just take probably that is also
giving him the square like if a knight
is on D 3 it can check me at least no no
I'm trying the same thing like this this
this put everything on this pawn it
should be a draw I mean it's just what
it is but him here I'm winning stuff he
gave me one or two more points
yeah yeah just being patient and not
doing something crazy some this is
enough sometimes thanks for watching